there are so many memorable moments from
harry potter and the philosopher's stone
i mean we grew up with this game guys
it's from our childhood all the way back
in 2001 when folks were still using
dial-up internet
that's actually what it sounded like if
you grew up playing harry potter then
once at the ready because today we're
busting out the time turners to relive
the 10 most memorable moments from the
pc version of harry potter and the
philosopher's stone it's gonna look like
guys what's it gonna look like
oh that is creepy
at number 10 we have dumbledore and his
glasses here comes albus welcome to
hogwarts school of witchcraft
look at his eyes
your headmaster
he's wearing 3d glasses
a game set in the wizarding world just
wouldn't be complete without getting to
fly on a broomstick and of course
quidditch by the way if you have fond
memories playing this game then see if
you can tap that like button before
harry catches the snitch in the next
clip yeah i don't even know if i have to
pay attention to those rings wait press
the jump button
yes let's go chat
we gotta win the house cup for
gryffindor you guys that's why this is
so important while the movies may have
pretended he never existed the video
games didn't make the same mistake at
number eight on our list we have run-ins
with peeves the poltergeist
speaking of peeps
what is this a boss battle dude he is
like taking away our health quickly
out with you we all know peeves wasn't
the only one to cause trouble for harry
in his first year at hogwarts there was
also school bully draco malfoy we are
gonna fight malfoy i can't i can't cast
spells guys
oh take that malfoy
wizard cracker to the face
oh he moved again the little punk get
away harry
we're almost dead guys we cannot let
malfoy get the better of us
take that malfoy
rubius hagrid was far more known for his
exquisite character model in the ps1
version of the game you're a wizard
harry but the pc version had some nice
moments with haggard as well including
harry helping him hatch norbert now
we're gonna turn these into our boy
hagrid
see if it helps to hatch norbert great
work harry you've collected all the fire
seeds i need
you've done it harry
it's hot let's go
where's norbert
yeah there he is
another pivotal character that was an
absolute must for the game is severus
snape and your first lesson with snape
in the dungeons is a memorable one
oh there he is dude
professor sleep go to the dungeons and
fetch the potion ingredients for the
class uh are we in the dungeons
and you know what snape's not the only
one you'll come across in the dungeons
you'll have an encounter with the bloody
baron as well
got another chest right here
what do we have here
oh the bloody baron dude he actually
hurts you what
oh my goodness i'm at half health
and he just closed that door
why is the bloody baron like one of the
strongest enemies in the game
for number four who could forget those
tense moments when you're trying to
sneak by filch and mrs norris
someone's got past me
not yet we haven't filled not yet
getting close though
yep come and investigate mrs norris
and then we are out of here
harry's first halloween at hogwarts was
a memorable one thanks to professor
quirrell and the mountain troll the
philosopher's stone video game certainly
took some creative liberties with this
encounter but it was no doubt another
memorable moment for the game i don't
think they know yet i don't think they
know yet dude
there he is
oh my goodness we got birdie bop beans
here
the controls are super bizarre and weird
and strange right now
but i'm going with it we're going to
make it happen
we've got to get away from this troll oh
here we go here we go
wait did we did we just lead him to the
girls bathroom
we did
oh my goodness we did
what's an adventure game without some
fun collectibles to search for along the
way in harry potter and the
philosopher's stone it was all about the
birdie bop beans and wizard cards hey
harry
do you have 25 beats oh
yes i do
hey you better get those that's it
that's all the beans we need what let's
go
come on new wizard card baby new wizard
card
okay turns out i can't limit this to 10
because there are still two ridiculously
nostalgic moments that just have to be
included of course we have to talk about
[Music]
[Music]
oh we got that we got that
98
and then perhaps the single most
nostalgic part of harry potter and the
philosopher's stone the music
if you'd like to see my full let's play
of the entire pc version of the game
check out the video on the right side of
your screen now to get started as always
thank you all so much for watching i'll
talk to you again soon